tyrosine metabolism in this video I'm
going to talk about tyrosine metabolism
and how it is associated with a genetic
disorder so as you can see this is the
structure of the tyrosine and its amino
acid and it's very important in our body
because many many biosynthetic pathway
requires these tyrosine so thyroid
hormone biosynthesis required tyrosine
so the precursor for thyroid hormone is
actually the amino acid tyrosine and the
catecholamine biosynthesis also require
tyrosine catecholamines means the
norepinephrine and epinephrine the
dopamine which is a inhibitory
neurotransmitter also require tyrosine
for production however melanin
production also depends upon tyrosine
that is why we should study the tyrosine
metabolism especially the tyrosine
catabolism and the enzyme involved in
this catabolism process and what happens
if these enzymes are mutated and what
disease we should develop if these
enzymes are mutated the genetic
disorders associated with these enzymes
so just metrical steps so first we what
we have here it's a phenyl alanine fill
an alanine you can see the structure the
feline alanine it has a phenyl group so
it's benzene green phenyl group again so
final Elaine would be converted to
tyrosine by phenylalanine hydroxylase
it's a hydroxyl s enzyme it will put a
hydroxyl group here you can see these
two structure differ only in the
hydroxyl group so this phenylalanine
hydroxylase will hydroxylate phenyl
alanine to convert it into tyrosine in
the next step
tyrosine would be converted by tyrosine
transaminase two hydroxy pyruvate and
any problem in this step will cause
tyrosinemia to just one thing to
remember that in this first step that
means the conversion of phenylalanine to
tyrosine is very important so
phenylalanine to tyrosine is converted
by
the phenylalanine hydroxylase and any
problem in this enzyme if this enzyme is
mutated or not working properly we will
develop a phenylketonuria and back to
the thing so we have para hydroxy
pyruvate para Hydrox final pyruvate
actually so this final pyruvate is
converted to homogenize it or
homogeneous t'k acid by beta hydroxy
phenylalanine dioxygen is so it's a
dioxygen is enzyme it will be
carboxylate these pyruvate and it will
form how much in ties it this is the
structure of the homogeneous set and
anything any problem in this step in
this enzyme will ultimately lead to
tyrosinemia type 3 again how much enjoys
it get converted to malai
acetate actually this rings break and it
forms the maligne acetate which is a
linear structure and this reaction is
catalyzed by a very important enzyme
that is how much in thai set 1/2 the
oxygen is homogenize it 1/2 the oxygen
is this is a dioxygen enzyme and this
enzyme is very important because if this
enzyme is mutated or this enzyme is not
functional or not present then we will
develop alkaptonuria
that means production of black urine so
from melon acetate it will be isomerized
to fumarole
acetate and this step is catalyzed by
isomers enzyme and from fumarole acetate
fumarole
acetic acid taste actually breaks this
fumarole acetate to acetoacetate and
fumarate you can see as it to acetate
and fumarate and this step is catalyzed
by fumarole acetoacetate any problem in
this enzyme will ultimately need to
tyrosinemia that is why this whole
catabolism pathway from phenylalanine to
these fumarate and
acetoacetate is very important because
almost all the enzymes involved in this
step if they are not functioning for
then it will lead to some disorders
actually these are disorders which are
associated with these enzymes as being
those metabolic disorders are actually
genetic any of because the gene for the
enzymes if the gene for these enzymes
are mutated or mutations in this gene
occur then functional enzymes would not
be produced and this whole pathway will
not be functional so that is why those
disease are developed hope you liked it
please subscribe and comment